♪ドン・ドン・ドン　ドンキ
♪ドンキホーテ
♪夜中に行ったらDQNに絡まれる～
（語呂があってない模様）
DQN「あ！はじめしゃちょーだ！！」
DQN「写真撮ってよ！写真！！
ねぇいいだろ？なぁ！？」
怖いよぅ…(´・ω・｀)
こんにちは　はじめしゃちょーです
夜中に後輩とドンキに行ったときに
衝撃的
超衝撃的な
セールを見つけてしまいました
あの、大抵カゴに入っている『〇〇円セール』
みたいなやつって
ある程度値段が分かると思うんすよ
みたいな いろんなセールがあるんですよ
俺が今回見つけたセールは…
世の中の常理、当たり前を覆すセールであった…
すごいよ…
ビビった ビビった マジ震えた 震えた
よく考えてみてくださいよ？
ドン・キホーテといえども
さすがに10円で物が売ってることなんて
そうそう無いんですよ！
モノって、単価より高く売るからはじめて利益が出る
ってことはその10円のカートの中に入っていた物は
10円以下の存在なんですよ
でも10円以下で物が作れることなんて
そうそう無いから買うだけでお得なんですよ
ヤバい！
ヤバい 俺…
俺どうしよ！？
…と思った僕は
もう気づいたら、一緒に後輩といたんですけども
見ないようにしたまま後輩に
そのカートの中の10円セールされていた物を
持ってこさせましょう…
あーこれに入れてもらったのね
なるほどなるほど
もう『10円』って聞いた瞬間、
買った瞬間アド（advantage）になると思ったので
全部買いました
単価が10円以下の物なんてほぼ無いから…
基本的に何が出てきても僕は嬉しいはずです
確実にプラス、利益になっているので こちらの
60個ぐらいはあったと思うんだよ
後輩：え？60個？？
え？
じゃあ100個とかは？
後輩：いやいやいやいやいや…
想像がつかんぞ…
待って 怖くなってきた……怖||´･д･)
後輩：いやいやいやいやいや…もっともっと
え、え、俺そんなに買ったの？？
え、８00．．．
後輩：おう！
え、きてる？！
820個くらいじゃない？
後輩:たぶん税抜きそれくらいすかねえ
800個もの買ったとしても8000円
俺はもう全部買うしか無いと思ったよ
独り占めするつもりで買ったんで
適当に見ていこうと思います
では行こう！
そもそもの話ですよ、800個これから開封っていうか見てくわけでしょ？
超流れ作業でいいですか？
皆さんは僕がこれを10円で手に入ったという認識で見てもらえるといいです
それでもう、うわーすげー入ってた
見た瞬間決めますよ、それが
10円で買ったことで、プラスなのかマイナスなのか
1っぱつめ
ガサガサ（あさる音）
はい！
なに？
フフっ
チュッパチャップスのシールですね
マイナス
やべえ、こういう感じで来るのか
怖いな、ちょっと怖くなってきちゃった
え、え、でかい
エー
すげえ　USBで聞けるスピーカーが十円で手に入ったぞ
ぷらす！
なんかこういう感じでどんどんいいやつが来るとね
あ、デコレーションシールだ　マイナス
800個全部見るのめんどくせーなー
どばっと行っちゃうか
どばっと行っちゃお、ちょっとこれきりがないぞ
一個ずつ見てたら日が暮れちまう！
この中から僕が選りすぐったいいやつを探していきましょう
こちらの商品すべて10円になっております
やあ！
どざざざざざ。。。（ものが落ちる音）
おお！
多いし、ちょっとまってこれもう商品に
ボロボロだなあおい！！
cfhj、、xfgjcf、djfg、jdrhg、gfxhgh、mdんxhxhjっfh、hっdfhdh